views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of eight news now
or next our media group tonight on
politics now we have a president-elect
reaction from the candidates as joe
biden is declared the winner
and all eyes have been on nevada how the
counting is going in a state that kept
the election tight for days
plus the balance of power in carson city
the ground republicans appear to have
made up and what it means for a
democratic agenda
from 8 news now this is politics now
tonight nevada is still counting the
votes but the presidential race has been
called by news outlets
joe biden is the next president of the
united states thank you for joining us
on politics now i'm john langler
and i'm vanessa murphy we have a lot to
get into
tonight president-elect joe biden gave a
speech tonight saying he would be a
president
to all americans i pledge to be a
president
who seeks not to divide but unify
who doesn't see red states in blue
states only sees the united states
and work with all my heart with the
confidence
of the whole people to win the
confidence of all of you
every little girl watching tonight
sees that this is a country of
possibilities
and to the children of our country
regardless of your gender our country
has sent you a clear message
dream with ambition lead
with conviction biden received the most
votes ever for a presidential candidate
74 million after the associated press
and the networks called the race this
morning
vice president-elect kamala harris made
this historic phone call
we did it we did it joe
you're going to be the next president of
the united states
harris is checking off a bunch of firsts
for a vice president
she will be the first female first black
american first asian american
and indian american to hold the job so
after days of
waiting and counting let's look at how
we got here now we should point out this
map has not yet been updated to show
pennsylvania and nevada so take that
into account because
the former vice president is now beyond
270 electoral votes but
it was this morning pennsylvania and
nevada were declared for the former vice
president pushing him beyond
270 electoral votes biden slowly grew
his lead here in nevada with each new
batch of numbers
the difference between the two
candidates now about 26 000 votes
that lead is being driven by clark
county and as you can see on your screen
there a good chunk of the votes for him
coming here from southern nevada another
interesting statistic from nevada's
presidential race
latino decisions look at your screen
here it reports 235 000 latinos cast
votes in nevada
68 percent of that vote went to joe
biden vanessa
president donald trump's reaction to the
associated press calling the election
has remained the same
alleging there is voter fraud in races
he is losing
here's what trump said earlier this week
if you count the legal votes i easily
win
if you count the illegal votes they can
try to steal
the election from us if you count the
votes that came in late
we're looking at them very strongly but
a lot of votes came in late
i've already decisively won many
critical states including massive
victories in florida
iowa indiana ohio trump went on to blame
tech companies polls and the media for
losing votes as the counting
continues while nevada has been called
for biden not all the votes have been
counted yet
slow but steady and accurate has been
the mantra for clark county election
workers
numbers have been released twice a day
once in the morning and once in the late
afternoon
we learned about 23 thousand votes were
counted since
yesterday and there are almost 100 000
more that still need to be counted
as far as the fraud being alleged by
republicans
clark county registrar joe gloria says
they are looking into any reports we do
have some reports that have come in that
we're logging we're reporting
and we're definitely going to do an
investigation
and we'll deal with them once the canvas
is finished
the votes are in the system at this
point so we'll have to
after the election post election go
after anything that's been reported at
this time
gloria says he expects to have the rest
of the mail ballots counted by tomorrow
mail ballot's postmarked by november 3rd
will be accepted until the 10th
then all the counting must be finished
by the 12th
after the race was called biden
supporters across the country took to
the streets to celebrate his victory
here in las vegas there was this car
parade at the commercial center district
along sahara
it was organized by the biden nevada
team there were more celebrations
scheduled for the weekend as well
meanwhile president trump's supporters
still protest outside the clark county
election department headquarters up in
north las vegas
they've been there every day since the
election carrying signs and chanting
stop the steal the group questions the
ballot counting process in nevada
and we're going to talk about that more
in just a moment vanessa first let's
take a quick look at the other big races
in nevada
democrat congresswoman dina titus and
republican congressman mark amaday
easily held on to their seats in
congressional district 3
incumbent democrat susie lee will hold
on to her seat
the associated press called that race
this morning
lee is ahead by about 12 000 votes this
was the closest of the congressional
races
it covers northwestern las vegas in
congressional district four
incumbent democrat stephen horsford
looks like he's going to hold on to his
seat
against republican challenger jim
marchant that seat covers north las
vegas and parts of lincoln and nye
county
and in a race that is still too close to
call the clark county commission
may have its first republican since
bruce woodbury left in 2008.
right now las vegas city councilman
stavros anthony is hanging on to a lead
of about 190 votes over democrat ross
miller miller was formerly secretary of
state in nevada
we're going to talk more about the races
a little bit later on in the program
for now though let's dig more into those
allegations of voter fraud vanessa
you've been covering this for several
weeks
yeah as you heard a minute ago president
trump has continued to make claims about
voter fraud even saying the election
would be stolen
in nevada as the i-team has been
reporting election officials and
leaders in law enforcement tell us it's
not widespread
and it's rare but if they receive
credible allegations
they'll investigate them i talked with
deputy secretary of state for elections
wayne thorley on wednesday and asked him
about voter fraud and
leading up to the election i talked with
both the fbi and the u.s postal
inspection about it here's what they
said
any evidence of voter fraud in nevada so
far
no no evidence whatsoever
of uh coordinated
widespread voter fraud
we have received a handful of complaints
with some allegations
again they're just allegations at this
point unproven uh that we're
looking into but no no evidence
of voter fraud and when you say we're
looking into
is that just the secretary of state's
office or is that when you pull in
perhaps the fbi whoever else
so yes it's it's uh we're pulling in our
partner agencies on the election
integrity task force
uh that includes the fbi um state and
local police
um so yes it's it's a joint effort
between
multi-jurisdictional is it widespread in
nevada i wouldn't say it's widespread
i would say that we get reports every
year every election cycle
of potential voter fraud situations and
we investigate them thoroughly
and we hold the people if it's uh if
it's
proven then we hold them accountable
through the us attorney's office
from your department's perspective is
voter fraud widespread through the mail
no as of right now i am unaware of any
credible reports of any voter fraud
being committed through the mail
on wednesday when i asked thorley to
specify a number about how many
allegations of voter fraud were being
investigated he said
less than 10. i reached out to the
department of justice friday to find out
any updates about any allegations of
voter fraud and did not receive
a response and there are also concerns
about how to confirm your mail ballot
was received there are two websites
where you can do that
we have links at eightnewsnow.com if you
mailed in your ballot as we've been
reporting
it may not have been counted yet so now
let's move on to signature verification
which is at the heart of some of those
trump campaign lawsuits
it's a small percentage of ballots that
have to go through the process
to confirm their signature which is also
known as signature
curing here's how the process works the
mail ballot is scanned in a machine to
make sure the signature matches
what's on file either from voter
registration a previous ballot the voter
signed or even
a driver's license there have to be
multiple and significant differences
in order for the signature to be
rejected then at least two
election workers review the signature if
they believe the signature cannot be
verified they must reach out to the
voter to give the voter a chance to
confirm
the signature is theirs they can use an
app through the secretary of state's
office or answer
personal questions through the
registrar's office and if that happens
the signature is then cured and the
ballot is counted
here's what deputy secretary of state
wayne thorley told me about that
wednesday
we'll still be waiting on some of these
cures to come in so it's a very
drawn out process and we tried to
prepare
voters and the public and candidates for
that after the passage of assembly bill
4
that look election results are going to
take much longer
than usual to become final and it's
simply because of these extra processes
the legislature put in place
voters have until november 12th to cure
their ballots
now here are the latest clark county
numbers from the secretary of state's
office nearly 6
000 ballots have needed curing just over
one percent of ballots cast
nearly 4 500 were successfully cured so
far
and about 1500 still need to be
coming up a blind woman who says her
ballot was stolen
i know i did not vote
and i'm not going to have this taken
away from me the i-team's david charns
broke the story of jill stokey now she's
at the center
of a lawsuit followed by republicans
it's next
welcome back to politics now
it is unacceptable in this country to
have illegal
votes counted and that is what's
happening
in the state of nevada that is nevada
trump campaign co-chair and former
attorney general here adam laxalt who
announced a fourth lawsuit on thursday
claiming illegal votes were being cast
however
did not provide any evidence of
widespread voter fraud at that time
vanessa
one person who did speak at that press
conference was a blind woman named
jill stokey our i-team has been looking
into these lawsuits and alleged voter
fraud across nevada and stokey reached
out to us monday
david charns was the one who broke her
story earlier this week and he's here
with more david well vanessa we broke
that story on jill stokey she's legally
blind and needs assistance to vote but
when she went to go
vote early a couple weeks ago she was
told she had already voted
stokey showed us the device she uses to
help her see
she says she went to vote in person but
was told that her mail-in
ballot had been sent in in that the
signatures matched
now she's part of that federal lawsuit
to stop clark county from using its
signature matching machine but a judge
denied an emergency motion for that on
friday
stokey is adamant she did not vote and
believes her ballot was stolen now
speaking
thursday clark county registrar joe
gloria didn't go
as far to say that stokey is lying but
said that in their mind
she voted i personally dealt with miss
stoke
she brought her claim to me we reviewed
the ballot and in our opinion it's her
signature
we also gave her an opportunity to
provide a statement
if she wanted to object to that and
provide a challenge to that she refused
to do so
a member of the nevada secretary of
state's office investigation team also
interviewed her
and they had no issue with the
assistance that we tried to give her
i have nothing else to comment on that
next question you heard that reporters
say do you think she's lying now this
lawsuit also alleged roughly 10 000
people who cast ballots here in nevada
no longer live here
it also claimed that dead voters voted
however
on friday lawyers provided no evidence
about those claims and in that hearing
friday they didn't even bring those
claims up to the judge
we have asked repeatedly to see that
evidence vanessa i know you
have asked as well and we have not seen
it vanessa
and david the lawsuit stokey is involved
in was denied a preliminary injunction
to stop counting friday right
yeah so they'd allege that the signature
verification system
that you've reported on was using lower
quality images
than the software requires but that
federal judge denied their motion to put
a stop to the counting or
change any rules about how the
observation process
is going john we'll keep an eye on it
dude republicans make some headway next
on politics now we break down the
shifting balance of power in carson city
and three new faces join the clark
county school district board
we're going to examine the sometimes
fractured group and how it'll look
moving forward
until the final vote is counted
welcome back 8 news now is also keeping
an eye on the balance of power up in
carson city
democrats control the state senate and
the state assembly but they appear to be
losing
some of that control i-team reporter
david charns looks at the balance of
power up in carson city david good to
see you
nice to see you so we are waiting for
those final results to come in remember
that those results by mail-in ballot can
come in through next tuesday
one of the most important races in the
state legislature is still swinging in
the balance but this is how it looks
right now so let's take a look democrats
we know will still hold power
in carson city but republicans did gain
some ground
in the state senate looks like democrats
will have 12 seats to the nine
republican ones but that's still up in
the air as these races
are called in the state assembly
democrats may lose
three seats they still will have control
but it's no longer
a super majority they'll be down to 26
16.
let's take a look at that at some of
these closer races now in senate
district six this is northwest las vegas
it's a nail biter right now
state senate majority leader nicole
canazzaro has taken
about a few hundred vote lead right now
over her republican opponent april
becker
becker led for the first few days after
the election
district five is an open seat in
henderson right now it's leading
republican
kerry buck leading by about a thousand
votes
a closer look at those state assembly
races republican
heidi kasama won this one in district
two republican richard macarthur running
ahead of
democrat incumbent connie monk in
district four
up in washoe county district 31 democrat
skip daley lost his seat to
his republican challenger jill ann
dickman is
real close there and district 37 shea
back is likely losing her seat
to andy matthews review journal
political editor and channel 8 political
analyst steve sebelius tells us
this means democrats won't be able to
push as much through the state house
they're going to need to make some
concessions since we have a democratic
governor
really the super majority is important
for two reasons one
you can override a governor's veto but
in this case a veto isn't likely since
democrats
hold the governor's mansion and both
houses of the legislature so
really the only other major thing that
requires a two-thirds vote
is raising taxes and we saw that happen
in the special session in which
democrats raised taxes with ease in the
assembly
and uh ran into trouble in the senate
they did it anyway
in the senate with a simple majority now
that of course is being challenged
in court so without that super majority
uh if it comes to tax increases they
would have to have republican
cooperation
for that and as we saw in the special
session they didn't really get that and
it looks like nicole cannizzaro will
hang on to that seat but as the top
democrat in the legislature here in
nevada that was a seat republicans
really targeted john we saw those ads
all over tv
a lot of attention poured onto that one
and it's interesting because one of the
things that was talked about
in the special session over the summer
was police reform bills that
might get passed up in carson city
canazarro has a lot of strong support
from
police unions and lobbyists they played
a big role in those bills back in 2019
she's a deputy district attorney in
clark county as well so we'll see how
all that plays out when the legislature
is back in session vanessa
well the clark county school district
board of trustees is about to have a new
look as well if the results hold it will
have three new faces
and all of the members will be women in
district a lisa guzman has a lead over
liberty
levitt in district b vocal trump
supporter katie williams has beaten jeff
profit evelyn garcia morales leads
tamika henry in district c
it appears school board president lola
brooks is keeping her seat
she leads teacher alexis salt in
district e
8 news now reporter kristen drummond
spoke with the presumptive winners about
the election
if the results stay the same it will
once again be all women
on the board with at least three new
faces because
long time board members are turning out
but a few presumptive winners are
hesitant to declare victory just yet
we're going to wait until the
every vote is counted cautiously
optimistic we're excited and we're
hopeful
clark county school board of trustee
candidates evelyn garcia morales and
lisa guzman stand by for the official
election results
i do want to wait and see what what
the votes say but katie williams seems
confident about her position
i actually spoke to dr jarrah this
morning he called me and congratulated
me
he was very nice and cordial on the
phone these women are the likely new
members joining the board next year
potentially bringing a different dynamic
after personality conflicts and division
over the superintendent's leadership
seemed to create tension in recent
months i hope it's different
they're being elected during an
uncertain time as the district navigates
the pandemic's economic and
academic fallout an issue the women seem
ready to address
now but approach differently when it
comes to students and staff returning to
the classroom
there is a lot of uncertainty when it
comes to reopening
schools right now especially without a
lot of information and a lot of data
i would like schools to be open fully
ready to bring their perspectives and
lead this new era of education
kristin drummond 8 news now ccsd school
board president lola brooks did send us
a statement on the state of the race
she says quote i'm happy with the
preliminary results and broad support
i've received during the election
i hope to continue representing district
d and students and families here in
clark county
next on politics now we take a closer
look at the tight race for a seat on the
nevada supreme court this is 8 news
now
you'll be here until the final vote is
counted
there was a hard-fought judicial race we
want to highlight the race for a nevada
supreme court seat
current clark county district court
judge douglas herndon has a comfortable
lead over assemblyman and attorney
ozzie fumo that had the most money
raised of
any of the judicial races herndon
outraised fumo and also got the help and
endorsement of current clark county
district attorney
steve wolfson as you know from filling
out your ballots this was the longest
ballot clark county
ever had part of that was due to so many
judicial races that were on it so
we have the most up-to-date minute
results on eightnewsnow.com
all right so there are a couple of key
election dates we're keeping an eye on
this week it is
in this week's what to watch on tuesday
at five that is the deadline for a
mail-in ballot to arrive
and be counted and it still has to be
postmarked by election day
we really don't know how many extra
mail-in ballots will come in
during the next few days but will be
watching and november 16th
is the day the official final results in
the election will be determined after
canvassing a canvassing board meets to
determine the status
of all provisional and challenged
ballots and then certifies
the election results and at that point
the 2020 election
will finally be over thank you for
watching politics now we're here every
saturday
good night
you